hi I'm Zach Weissmuller with reason here
with my colleague Nick Gillespie and as
well as our special guest Jesse Powell
the co-founder and current CEO and soon
to be chair of Kraken one of the world's
largest cryptocurrency exchanges it's a
real pleasure to have the opportunity to
speak with someone in your position with
your institutional knowledge about all
this so first of all thank you very much
for joining us today Jesse
thanks for having me
better circumstances I thought he was
talking to me but okay
yeah so yeah well under this is not I
just uh I mean it's not the worst of
circumstances right it's pretty bad no
no 10 billion dollar hole I don't know
second to maid off yeah
yeah so what we're talking about here is
the Meltdown and bankruptcy of FTX uh
under the stewardship of its founder Sam
bankman freed and I just want to lay out
some of the key facts at the top here
before we dig deeper
um FTX which if you're not familiar with
the crypto economy you can kind of think
of them as a bank that holds
cryptocurrency deposits um and also
offers kind of interest bearing products
and they loaned about uh 10 uh sorry 10
billion dollars of those customer
deposits which is more than half of
their total deposits out to its sister
company a hedge fund called Alameda
research which is run by bankman Freed's
apparent ex-girlfriends Caroline Ellison
and then as crypto dips and a number of
Alamitos big bets failed to pay off uh
and it became apparent that it was using
huge amounts of its own in-house
cryptocurrency as loan collateral the
entire house of cards kind of collapsed
and the sort of bank run ensued and FTX
had to pause withdrawals declare
bankruptcy uh the future of Sam Beckman
free it is certainly an interesting
question uh but perhaps even more
important to us here is the future of
the crypto economy itself and uh its
relationship with the regulatory state
so to kick it off I want to just talk
first a little bit about the personality
and the media image of bankman freed or
SBF that sees popularly known before we
get into some of those meteor issues
about crypto and regulation
um and even the talk of a potential
introduction of things like a central
bank digital currency
um I think a way to get into that is to
look a bit at the contrast in how
someone like SBF was portrayed in the
media versus say someone like Mew Jesse
Powell there was a Forbes article from
October this year that looked at some of
the internal office politics of Kraken
and and this is what they had to say uh
about Jesse Powell they said Pals
anti-woke views on things like gun
rights and maternity leave uh were a
problem
unlike uh Sam bankman freed who's
positioned himself as a media darling
ever defiant pal 42 had become a
liability
so could you talk uh Jesse a little bit
about
the person the personality and kind of
the media phenomenon of Sam bankman
freed from your perspective
sure well you know who knows how much of
it is real because he's come out and and
said that basically he just said
whatever needed to be said to earn the
most favor with whoever he was
interacting with and um
you know he says that basically he
disagrees with all the woke stuff and
you know he was just you know
saying what they wanted to hear
but with with the public with the media
with Washington DC and Regulators he
held himself out to be this uh effective
altruist this uh Wizkid billionaire who
was gonna give it all away to charity he
wasn't doing it for for profits or for
himself I mean he actually did say he
was doing it for profits he had no
interest in cryptocurrency or or Bitcoin
or you know what that could do for
Humanity he was just here strictly to
make money in order to give it away to
somebody else later
and he gave a lot of it away to
politicians in Washington uh over
himself alone uh I think it was like 40
million dollars uh 10 million dollars to
Biden alone and um
across this whole group and the
companies and everything I mean it was I
think 250 million dollars thing in that
range uh so
um from from my perspective and everyone
else uh I think we believe that Sam was
was a deep you know hardcore Democrat
who uh was
um fully in bed with the DC apparatus
and you know his his family has ties
back to The Regulators of some uh some
relationships there like through mid and
through
um their jobs
so um
uh the families are also you know big
Democrat boosters so uh he was certainly
playing that role of
being the guy who's going to you know be
the media darling tell them what they
want to hear appeal to the sensibilities
of uh whoever's writing the piece
um you know he had been he was slated to
speak on a panel for the New York Times
kind of a lunch coming up
you know zielinski and like uh Yellen
and you know a bunch of big shots
uh so it's kind of interesting how
effective that strategy actually was and
how deep he was able to get and how much
really positive coverage he was able to
get from the media who is uh especially
Publications like the New York Times uh
who historically just trash anything
related to Tech you know I mean
as you might have seen with the story
about about me and Kraken I mean they
were
uh they were taking the word of a few
former disgruntled employees to write
this like soap opera gossip piece out
Kraken
um and uh you know when Sam obviously
has stolen 10 billion dollars from from
maybe a million people and completely
ruined their lives uh they write this
puff piece which is just like oh whips
like I kind of like you know didn't
really like keep track of the numbers
and I just like accidentally lost 10
billion dollars sorry guys
yeah can I ask a a kind of general
question do you think investors or you
know crypto users or you know just
customers of any you know kind of
company should you should your radar
immediately go up when a company is
being fronted by somebody who seems to
be you know the wet dream of the media
or something you know a lot of people
are comparing him to Elizabeth Holmes of
theranos and it's kind of looking back
at that you know and I mean I'm happy to
say reason was kind of you know a little
bit on you know a little bit ahead of
the curve on that but like when you see
somebody who's checking off every box
that you want and running a company that
is going to revolutionize things like
that's the time to say I've really got
to start doing due diligence
yeah I think so I mean red flags went
off for me it was it was like this
character is like too good to be true
you know for for the media and um
you know so many players in the space
are just extremely authentic people are
in this for the value of crypto and what
crypto can do for the world and uh
there's there's this General kind of
libertarian and to like uh you know the
movement
um so to see a guy like Sam come out and
just go so hard in that direction which
is really bizarre for the space I mean
you basically never see that to get so
much traction uh that strategy
um
was a surprise I think to everyone it's
also quite interesting to see
kind of behind the curtain now we've
seen a few glimpses as to how authentic
or inauthentic this this really was and
I want to give our viewers a sense of
kind of the image that he was putting
out there there's this video uh that I'm
going to pull up in a second that uh
kind of uh explains uh Sam uh bankman
Freed's uh effective altruism he was
known for
um being a big proponent of this
movement called uh the effect of
altruism movement and this is kind of
how he was generally portrayed Because
he believes in the concept of earn to
give which means his goal as a human is
to make as much money as possible just
to give it away earn to give and that's
exactly what he's doing so let's say
that you have a hundred dollars and you
want to figure out what you can do with
it to help the world
Ernie to give is thinking about which
causes which charity saves the most
per dollar this hundred dollars can go
as far as they possibly can to help the
world last year this 29 year old guy
donated 50 million dollars next year he
is planning to donate 500 million
dollars a year and next decade he will
probably give away more than 10 billion
dollars
uh and then um
there is this interesting uh text
exchange that was revealed by a box
reporter where
um you know she asks him you know you
were really good at talking about ethics
uh for someone who uh kind of saw it all
as a game with winners and losers and
then he goes yeah haha I had to be it's
what reputations are made of to some
extent uh I get I feel bad for those who
get [ __ ] by it by this dumb game we
woke westerners play where we say all
the right shibboleths so Everyone likes
us
um what what is your reaction Nick to
kind of this disconnect between the
image and the reality that has been
revealed and kind of like what the the
underlying ethical structure
how that may have affected how this all
played out well you know I want to go
back to something Jesse uh touched on
just a minute ago you know when he said
that uh SPF was not particularly
interested in crypto or Bitcoin or this
technology and its possibilities for
human Freedom I'm in between uh uh
sessions at the atlas Network which is a
a group that facilitates think tanks in
the developing World especially in
authoritarian places and they talk a lot
about how Bitcoin is you know is a
technology of freedom and it's you know
it's disturbing to me that a guy would
say you know like I you know I just want
to get rich and I could be you know I
could be selling my pillow but that was
taken so now I'm going to try and uh you
know and use crypto to get there to do
what I say and and I guess
um you know PT Barnum who was uh you
know was known as the greatest showman
on Earth and whatnot uh we wrote a piece
of I would published piece like in 2000
or 2003 about how he helped invent
business ethics because he realized
early on he could promote a show saying
like you're going to see something
spectacular but not deliver and people
know it's a fake and you can get their
money once you know and then that's it
or you can actually deliver what you
promise and then you you know you build
a business and a relationship with
people and and just I guess to bring it
to the crypto moment and you know I mean
part of what's great about Bitcoin in
particular but other cryptocurrencies is
that kind of what you see is what you
get like there's you know in an it it
comes close to the being a not [ __ ]
world like it's not fiat currency uh
reputation matters but in the end it's
like is the transaction in The Ledger or
something so like I mean could you just
maybe respond to that and then also talk
about how does crypto
um you know uh you know make the make
people more free how to why is it a good
thing in the world in and of itself
apart from you know it's gonna get
slappy now because SBF was a was a fake
yeah and I think it's really important
to draw that distinction between
SBF the fraud he committed and
cryptocurrency right uh Bernie madoff's
scam is not an indictment of the stock
market or Wall Street or you know
equities in general and I really hope
that everyone sees that what Sam did was
just standard run-of-the-mill fraud it
just so happens that he happened to to
defraud cryptocurrency users
unfortunately and you know I think the
reaction in Washington they're looking
for any reason to clamp down on
cryptocurrency is going to be to say
well this this obviously needs more
rules when when that's not really the
case in fact if it had less rules more
people might actually use it might not
have been using a service like FTX where
they got screwed
uh but to your point about transparency
you know you write everything on the
blockchain is is there forever
um anyone can track back what happened
and surely you know Twitter
investigators crypto sleuths have
already kind of put a lot of these
pieces together through the the data
available just on the blockchain and it
goes back to the beginning of of time
for each particular chain so
um you know you might have seen there
have been a few cases where uh law
enforcement the FBI IRS have found
people that committed a hack like three
years five years back uh just through
you know they eventually slip up some at
some point in the future they use that
Bitcoin with some kyc vendor or
something like that and um they're able
to track it all the way back to uh to
where um they actually stole the funds
so
um yeah it's full transparent
um
so the good good stuff it does for the
world you know it's it's a rail of Last
Resort for people who are left out of
the banking system and that's about two
billion people today who just don't have
access to uh the normal financial
services that we all have access to in
the developed World
um
and uh you know
we're just kind of like stumbling over
access to financial services here in the
U.S so it's sometimes hard to to
understand that we had a conversation
with someone in the treasury Department
in the U.S who said why would anyone you
Bitcoin because my credit card works
just fine
and you know I think that just shows
like a fundamental lack of understanding
about the rest of the world and and the
amount of financial privilege and access
that we have here and um
you know what Bitcoin provides you know
it's kind of bizarre that we have this
post office as sort of a rail of Last
Resort for sending physical mail around
uh but you can't really live these days
without access to banking system and
there's no there's no public guarantee
a government guarantee to be able to
have a bank account the banks can just
shut you off if they want to and you
know it's extremely hard to have a
business without a bank account so um
you know I don't know if you're familiar
with operation choke point but basically
this whole thing to basically ban
through the the abuse of the banking
system businesses which are totally
legal uh you know like the sale of of
weapons or guns or pornography or you
know marijuana
um to basically have the banks shut
these businesses down uh just as
basically like a business decision
rather than making it about the law uh
and then just basically you know in
facto like kind of ban those businesses
through through the banking system
without actually having to make new laws
um so Bitcoin is you know a refuge for
those people
um it's that rail of Last Resort that
they can go to
uh when the banking system shuts them
out and you know the banking system
might shut up for a number of reasons
you know maybe they're just born in a
place where they don't have a birth
certificate a social security number
whatever it takes to get kyc and pass
that bar too I mean kyc is know your
customer laws right yeah exactly so like
if you don't have you know government ID
you can't get one
um you know Banks want you to make a
minimum deposit
so does it cost to actually open the
account there might be a cost to
maintain the account so it could just be
cost prohibitive for some people to
maintain a bank account
um so there's there's the basic uh
gates to to like actually getting an
account but then they're like you know
other reasons why you might not want to
rely on the banks in a time of emergency
and something we saw in Ukraine was uh
people trying to flee the country and
the ATMs are out of cash
and so what do you think the branch is
closed the ATMs are out of cash you're
trying to get out of the country
you're screwed you know you're gonna
have like hitchhikers before we move
into the more more specifics about FTX
and and the coming regulatory likely
regulatory Onslaught um let's uh dilate
a little bit over the you know the the
public image of SBF
um you know part of the you know the
Press is going to be drawn on and the
politicians too to the salacious parts
of this you know that he's in a
polyamory you know you know a bunch of
people living a Club Med lifestyle all
like screwing and taking drugs together
I assume that's everyday life for you
and everybody else who's involved in any
kind of crypto uh currency is you know
do you worry about that kind of you know
you know like fixation on on business
people's personal lives particularly if
it seems to confirm some higher calling
or something there's also this issue
I'll just throw in there the that uh
this tweet I'm showing from an account
called autism Capital which is really uh
brought forth some interesting Scoops
but one is that uh it looks like SPF was
probably on this uh Parkinson's
medication that he was using as a kind
of nootropic like brain enhancement so
that's another Wrinkle In Here is the
kind of role of stimulants or other
nootropics and like driving increasingly
risky Behavior but uh yeah to Nick's
question
um what do you think about I guess like
the kind of of crypto culture question
hanging over this
well I'm just probably getting laid more
than most guys in crypto but you know
he's doing it without going to the gym
very much you know so yeah
every uh yeah every Ash you know extra
hash you can have an extra 10 pounds so
I think we lost your uh audio there for
a second oh how is it now oh you're back
yeah
um you know I don't know much about
his lifestyle you know like I I lived in
San Francisco for seven years so I've
heard it all in terms of like you know
personal relationship dynamics that uh
people want to have
um
yeah I think it's clear from a bunch of
interviews that he's done you know he's
he's on something he's constantly
jittering and uh he kind of like Rambles
on so
um you know who knows what I mean the
reports are basically that you know he
was living in this 10 bedroom apartment
it's like you know orgy's going on drugs
used all the time
um it's it's just like that's the future
Libertarians want right
I mean if if uh we could do that all day
every day I don't have to worry about
anything else that would be great uh so
you know I I don't know is
you know it's to know what's what's true
at least from my perspective you know I
don't know I'm sure it wasn't I it
wasn't totally you know uh as
Sensational as it's made out to be
you know the guys got to run a business
at some point but um
you know it certainly sounds like they
didn't have much of a structure there uh
they didn't have much process much uh
much for controls uh they certainly
weren't auditing anything or reconciling
their books
um it doesn't sound like they had very
much experience leadership in the
company
and uh you know it kind of sounds just
like a bunch of kids got together and uh
you know instead of
building this out of the garage or
building it out of you know luxury
houses in the Bahamas and um
it's just blowing my mind that uh these
VCS that threw hundreds of millions of
dollars into this did not do any
Dillards apparently
yeah can I ask also just I mean because
you're you're a hardcore capitalist and
you know in the very best sense of the
world word
do you worry that this type of you know
now it's getting conflated you know like
we love SPF because he's not a
capitalist he's not making money because
he likes making money he's doing it so
he can help everybody and now the script
is flipping and it's going to become
like oh well this is what Ultra Rich
capitalists and innovators do they
defraud people they live these separatic
Lifestyles so we gotta we really gotta
lock it down not just the technology but
also the whole thing I mean this I you
know friends of mine who are Jewish
always talk about how like any time you
know if you know when Harvey Weinstein
was arrested they were like God this
isn't good for the Jews in a way with
crypto it's kind of like this isn't good
for the capitalists right
yeah I think this is one guy you know
just like Weinstein was one guy and made
office one guy
um
certainly most people in crypto that I
meet are super awesome people who just
want what's good for the world and
they're very ideologically driven uh
fortunately not by you know some kind of
like uh crazy version of utilitarianism
but
um
you know most people want want good
things you know they got into the space
to to change the world and really to
help people and to push crypto forward
they're not here first and foremost to
make money you know I think Sam saw
cryptos and as a means to an end and
most people in the space see crypto as
the end goal of delivering that that's
what we need to deliver to humanity
so
um yeah his his ideas certainly were I
think in conflict with the rest of the
industry that the point that you're
bringing up earlier about kind of the
the roots of cryptocurrency and this
idea of creating more of a parallel
economy that is less reliant on
centralized institutions and Banks and
you you mentioned a number of examples
another one that comes to my mind that I
did a short documentary on was the
Canadian truckers situation and uh you
know they got totally cut off their
their fundraising efforts got totally
cut off and however you personally feel
about the politics of the Canadian
truckers it was interesting because what
I covered was a Bitcoin based fundraiser
that had some problems but essentially
it was the only currency that was able
to get through at the end of the day and
it it came down to a guy just handing
out uh paper wallets for people to load
onto their phones
um so that is kind of the roots of
crypto but SPF clearly was trying to
push things into a much more regulatory
regulated space and that in a way was
the beginning of his downfall I want to
bring up this coindesk article which
really kind of started to break open the
problems
um which showed that you know a lot of
their assets were held in this coin that
they themselves issued
um and uh there's another big play uh
this is just a tweet of him saying that
they don't invest client Assets in
anything else clearly now no that is a
lie
um the CEO of binance which is really
the kind of heavy weight in this
industry
um had come in uh and obviously a rival
to FTX but also came in and
initially it offered to buy them up or
and kind of offered a an off-ramp for
them when he looked into the finances
he saw the problems and started tweeting
about it
um and that kind of initiated the bank
run
one of the tweets that he made was very
interesting I have highlighted here uh
we won't support people who Lobby
against other industry players behind
their backs
um so it seemed that what uh bankman
Freed's and I'm curious if you agree
with this what his agenda here was was
to create what they call a regulatory
moat
around themselves where they kind of
become the one uh regulated entity and
it sort of elbows out the competition uh
and this angered his rival and and that
ended up being a problem for him
there's been talk about the SEC head
Gensler
and how he kind of failed to act and was
maybe on the same page as SPF and sort
of sort of creating this new regulated
space
um this is from a fortune article uh
according to Washington insiders the
reason behind SBS decision this summer
to obtain control over block fi which is
also now freezing all of its customers
assets was to benefit from the troubled
crypto lenders recent settlements with
the SEC basically extending the amnesty
blackfy had received two FTX so from
your Vantage Point as someone who runs a
uh an exchange that I assume is subject
to some regulations
what do you think about the approach
that he was taking to these regulatory
issues
yeah I mean it's
it's very problematic because
um held himself out as a representative
for
for all of crypto for the whole industry
and at the same time was
look just very self-interested and
um what he was trying to do was was
basically offer a trade to Washington uh
through legislation to
basically sacrifice some ground that I
think belongs to the world in defy
and uh you know trade that for uh you
know big remote for himself his own
civilized business so you know he was
saying all right you guys can um we'll
give you well kyc all the wallets
if you want to use Bitcoin you got to
get uh seed in exchange for that
um I can trade derivatives in the United
States for example
um so he's doing stuff like that and um
that really rubbed people the wrong way
when they found out about it because you
know we obviously feel like Defy is not
his to trade away and you know if
anything we should be giving up the
freedoms of these centralized venues
which have you know just been the
problem all along uh which is why the re
the reason for Bitcoin existing in the
first place you know we should be giving
up those freedoms to get more freedom uh
for D5 for for the crypto native
platforms
uh so you know from the perspective of
of other people in the industry he was
doing the complete opposite of of
somebody with good intentions you know
or with you know a moral philosophy
would actually do so um yeah we're all
very upset when we found out what he was
doing
uh and just to give a perspective there
on defy uh decentralized Finance you
know uh FTX was big but the the the size
of defy at this point is is way bigger
than you know he he represents just a
slice of that this is a graph showing
you know at one point over 120 billion
locked into D5 projects now a little bit
less than 80 billion so huge emerging
industry
um but Nick did you have any uh
questions about you know deep eye or
yeah three implications well one of the
questions Jesse is how how do Industries
you know particularly emerging
Industries
um kind of get you know block the
regular I mean I I sorry to
um falling over my own words here but
you know I mean he was seeking to
capture The Regulators for his own
Advantage it's an emerging technology
and I'm thinking back you know maybe 10
years a little bit more
uh when Uber uh you know Uber in like
the DC area you know they they you know
they were permissionless innovation in
San Francisco and New York and they
showed up in DC and Northern Virginia
and then when they reached a certain
point they were like hey you know what
they went to the legislature in Virginia
and said you know we agree with you we
gotta you know we should have rules and
we should have all of these kinds of uh
setups to make sure that our drivers are
safe and the customers are safe et
cetera and it was just a way to lock
themselves into the market
um that is always going to happen uh
particularly in emerging Industries like
crypto or D5 or whatever how do you
guard against that
um because this is you know one of the
problems right is that like you know at
a certain point
um you know as a businessman it makes
sense to go to the government and say
hey let's talk terms of surrender or
negotiated settlement
um you know how do you keep away from
that kind of thing because it ends up
you know that company or the the
industry might do well the government
does well but then the customers are
kind of hung out to dry
yeah it's a really tough problem
especially in financial services because
there's so much law there and there's
already you know as incumbent players
who have their moats who've captured uh
the political apparatus uh through all
the the money that they make through the
laws and monopolies that they've
obtained through doing that so it's
super difficult I mean Skype faced a
similar problem uh when they launched
fighting with the telcos and the
existing laws and
um you know they were being treated with
the same rules as a telephone company
when really they weren't they were you
know for their IP company uh and so I
had just very different architecture and
million reasons why they should not be
treated like a Telco
uh but you know the talk was there
saying
yeah you guys should be treated like a
Telco because of course they're scared
they don't they don't want Skype to eat
their lunch and so um you know sometimes
you have
just bad laws in place that have not
predicted the future and a new
technology emerges and and the laws need
to be changed and um that's where we're
at with a lot of the the regulation that
captures crypto right now so that these
laws are 80 100 years old uh you know
they're contemplating orange groves and
you know traditional Commodities uh
never imagined the internet much less
Bitcoin or cryptocurrency so
we we really need change at the
legislature The Regulators are out there
just looking to put notches on their
belt and so you know they they see
something and they they go after it and
it doesn't really matter to them
if if that's good public policy or not
you know or if they're crushing in
Industry that's very important to to
their country
um
so for us as an industry you know we've
got a lobbying team at Kraken we've got
guys in DC full-time
many of the other players in the
industry do as well we have several
industry associations uh so like
blockchain Association there's um coin
Center which is a great think tank that
looks out for the space
um
there are many industry groups that are
are working behind the scenes in DC to
try to educate uh politics and make sure
that ballot does not get uh get through
and that good law does get written but
it's a constant battle you know as you
say there's
there's a the side that would love to be
crypto destroyed because it's bad for
their business just like Skype was bad
for the telcos and um and then there's a
site of crypto the people that um you
know are trying to defend this new
technology because of all the great good
it's going to do for Humanity I mean
imagine if voice over IU were banned and
we all had to keep using telcas to to
well this none of this would be
happening right exactly
I'm curious Jesse about this initiative
that uh I know Kraken signed on to years
ago this was back in 2013 uh it was kind
of an effort to self-regulate among some
of the big players in the industry the
digital assets transfer agency I believe
was called
um what do what role do things like that
play in this conversation of the ability
of Industry to kind of kind of try to
set best practices without the
government coming in or is that just
kind of like temporarily trying to keep
them at Bay until the inevitable
clampdown happens
um good question so we tried to to
launch a self-regulatory organization
okay
um in and I think it was 2014 or 2013
and uh called Data the digital asset
transfer Authority and um we were hoping
to develop something kind of like a
finra you know which is basically like a
non-government agency but
um that worked government that has some
Authority from the government to
actually enforce
um what it's doing so you know we we
launched it um there was some interest a
few players got involved but
um you know because because we existed
to basically put controls on the
industry
a lot of people just said well that
sounds like putting myself at a
competitive disadvantage to join that so
unless you can get everybody in there
then you know why would I be the first
or the next to go in there you know I'm
kind of going to wait I would like to be
the last one to go here if ever
so um you know we had this problem where
where the members were were
disadvantaged basically versus their
competitors were able to be more fast
and loose with their business and not
adhere to the same kind of constraints
and um we tried to get some support from
the government you know and actually
this this works pretty well in Japan we
have a self-regulatory organization
there
um that we helped found and we're a
member of and that actually has some
teeth you know that the government
leans on that to basically uh vet other
players in the industry and identify you
know potential enforcement issues and
things like that so um it actually has
some power and and you have to be a part
of that group uh to be licensed in Japan
so
very different from the from the US here
and I think something like that could
work but it really
so your audio dropped up oh yeah looks
like you're muted
yeah you're back uh you said it could
work like that here but it would need
something additional yeah we would just
need the government support to do it you
know it just has to have some kind of
authority to implement the consequences
so is that uh and that would be more
like uh you know kind of like an
underwriter's Underwriters Laboratory or
ASTM which sets standards as opposed to
like the movie writing system which
doesn't really matter anymore but you
know the MPAA ratings were put in place
because the government said if you don't
do this we're going to regulate
um but you know do you do you think it
would be possible to you know develop
industry-wide self practice you know
best practices that are then kind of
publicized and enforced
yeah I think it's good to do that you
know we um unfortunately we have
companies all over the world
and uh you know what would be a disaster
is to have like a different regime for
every country yeah where you know we
have like just different rules
significantly different rules everywhere
so it would be nice to have some kind of
uniform
uh rules however
um you know they could get it wrong as
well you know I mean we wouldn't want
rules that exist in Japan in the states
and we wouldn't want New York's rules in
California
um because you know Japan is extremely
conservative
uh we have to get pre-approval to to
launch support for our new token and
they might take six months to to think
about it and to approve it
and um you know that doesn't really
allow us to be competitive in the market
with other players outside who you know
maybe they can they can support a token
whenever they feel like it we've got six
months so um you know you first and
foremost I think you don't want to put
the good actors at a competitive
disadvantage
and um in a second I think if you if you
are going to enforce these kinds of
rules you have to do it universally
basically you can't let the bad guys
keep getting away with it because then
it's just a slap in the face to the good
guys you know who I mean basically
you're you're buying protection you
should be anyway you know and that's a
problem that was a problem to FTX as
well and why how they were able to be
successful is they went offshore
um for doing stuff illegally basically
stuff that crack and coinbase Gemini
could never get away with because we've
been around for so long we're so heavily
supervised that uh you know coinbase
that's the SEC for permission to to do
this like four percent yield product in
the United States and the SEC said no
meanwhile FTX is doing the same thing
offshore for like 10 yields and um and
getting away with it so you know
basically what the SEC has said is
um you know if you're on Shore if you're
in our backyard we're going to shut you
down your target if you're offshore well
you know you're kind of hard to go after
so you know do it do whatever you want I
mean you know they would say officially
yeah that's illegal but unofficially
they're just kind of a hassle to go
after so like you know we can't really
stop them in the in the long run is
there any substitute for you know kind
of individual I I responsibility might
be the wrong word but you know
individual responsibility and kind of
literacy about what you're investing in
or where you're putting your money
um because it seems like no matter what
whatever regulatory regime whatever best
practices you come up with
there's always going to be bad actors
and
um you know it seems also the crypto uh
at this stage is you know most people's
understanding of it is zero and even
people who are aware of it it's you know
we're in the real early stages of it but
ultimately you got to be saying to
people like don't put money into things
that you don't understand or that you
can't afford to lose Etc and that you
know that kind of caveat of mtor
um mindset which is is not the greatest
world to live in but it might be the
only one where you can really make sure
that you're not going to get screwed and
I'll just add on to that it's also
pretty clear that what SPF did was
illegal I mean it was fraud regardless
of whatever kind of preemptive
regulations you put on something uh you
know taking so telling someone that
their money is an account that you're
actually using it to leverage your other
company that is Broad and you don't
really need complex located Financial
regulations to prosecute fraud so what
really does this tell us about the need
for more regulation of crypto or can it
be brought down more to the kind of
individual caveat mtor level
yeah certainly an aspect of doing your
own research you know I think that um
it's hard to expect everyone to to
actually do that research I mean even
even for the stock market right people
are investing in yeah in stocks that
they really they haven't done the
fundamental research they're not sitting
in on on the the annual calls or you
know the quarterly reports or anything
like that they're they're just basically
like oh do I like Apple cool I'll buy
some Apple stock like they don't know
what the balance sheet looks like or
anything like that so
um
yeah I think that's always going to be a
thing
um you know I think a lot of the the
problems with FDX came from this kind of
like Confidence Game around it and their
ability to like build all this status
you know part of the reason why you
would you would invest in Apples because
they've been around for a long time they
have all this status
um you know they're well regarded among
your friends and in the media and
you know FTX also managed to build this
like this extremely high status thanks
to the mainstream media puffing them up
constantly and thanks to the donations
that they've been giving and you know
this the whole Persona you know I think
just played very well um with the media
um so that's a problem is just that kind
of facade that they were allowed to
create like without completely without
um
any kind of like critical judgment or
analysis from the mainstream media that
was giving them all this like fluffy
coverage from from venture capital
uh you know and you see those uh when
you see a name like Sequoia
on a company and they've written a nine
figure check you think oh they must have
looked into this they must have done
some diligence they're not just blindly
writing nine-figure checks to people
but turns out they actually did just
blindly right check
and uh I think in doing so you know they
put their name on something and people
looked at that and they thought oh
that's a stamp of approval that's you
know some kind of seal of authenticity
so I can trust this company
and um yeah I mean it what raises a lot
of eyebrows now with this portrait that
has emerged and the uh kind of yes the
The Fluffy coverage
um is there we now know I mean that he
was a large donor uh political donor
um specifically to the Democratic party
he gave to some Republicans as well but
this chart here on the left shows that
he's the number six political donor at
the federal level for 21 22 the number
two to the Democratic party behind
George Soros uh gave about
38.7 million dollars
um so
how does that factor into this equation
uh what do you think he was up to here
with this kind of massive campaign of
political donations going into the
midterms
well I think he was looking for
political favor with with The Regulators
I think he knew that he was trouble and
doing a lot of shady stuff and I think
he had a lot of liability out there I'm
sure he was facing some uh he from ofac
and from the SEC and you know probably
from many other relatives over the way
that he had operated his business
and um
you know I'm sure he's kind of trying to
buy his way out of trouble and um you
know I think these donations also play
very well with with the mainstream media
um and so you know I think it was all
part of a marketing campaign in a facade
that he put on you know
it's uh you know this is sort of a
combination of of Madoff and uh theranos
together because you know he was just
like theranos he was able to attract
um all of these well-respected people
who had you know unimpeachable
reputations
get those people around him to to vouch
for him and um you know I think by
making all these political contributions
you know he sort of bought that kind of
status he was on stage uh with Tony
Blair and Bill Clinton at his conference
uh so you know I think by surrounding
himself with all these people and making
all these donations it's all just you
know this this status play to show that
he's you know the super virtuous guy and
you know he's aligned with the the
current Administration and
um you know maybe it would be
politically unfavorable to to prosecute
him for some of the things that he's
doing you know or at least at least you
know if you're the SEC maybe he's not
going to be at the top of your list
um you know a couple of days ago in a
tweet Thread about this
um which I recommend everybody check out
it Jess Powell uh on Twitter
Europe please as an industry we have to
recognize the signs believe people when
they show tell us who they are the first
time shame them and shut them out if we
don't they'll take us down with them
when they inevitably destroy themselves
don't trust verify are there other
players in the crypto world that you
want to call out right now that are that
are Bad actors
you know it's very hard to know what's
going on behind the scenes at these
companies
um
you know I think something that people
can look at and they're you know there's
many red flags with FTX but
um you know I don't think any of the
other CEOs are sort of like as
egregiously trying to buy political
favor like that or you know appeal to
mainstream media
um but things are you know like do they
have a token and
does that token do anything does it have
a reason to exist or is it just to
inflate their own balance sheet
um do you have a reason to believe that
they're engaged in a ton of lending
activity
um you know a lot of these guys that
have blown up recently
uh were taking out huge loans they were
hugely leveraged and uh what they were
using for collaterals other tokens with
basically zeroquidity you know and like
this ftt token
um that FTX had was was their own token
and
really very illiquid
and um they were taking out client loans
basically against that so
um you know what else to look for I
think longevity in this space is
something that people can can look at
you know kraken's 11 years old coinbase
I think is also 10 or 11 years old
um there are a bunch of companies that
have been around you know and I think if
you've survived this long if you've
survived over a decade in the space
probably doing something right
FTX emerged in 2019
so they hadn't been really through a
bear Market cycle you know they hadn't
had to deal with a credit crunch yet so
um
I think looking at those companies that
have been around longer
um probably safer you also again this
we'll we'll try and put this in the show
notes or the page but you also say U.S
lawmakers and Regulators have some
accountability too you drove this
business offshore because you refused to
provide a workable regime under which
these Services could be offered in a
supervised manner enforcement wrongly
focuses on convenient onshore good
actors you know clearly you know the the
crypto industry is is going to be making
a lot of visits to Washington are being
called on the carpet that type of stuff
are there who are the people in Congress
that kind of get crypto you know and are
not going to be wowed by somebody who's
giving them money or is talking about
effective altruism but is actually
explaining the potential of this
technology
um to increase human flourishing I mean
who are there do you have allies in
Congress that um that are worth kind of
reaching out to or knowing who they are
yeah there are quite a few actually and
and they're increasing a number uh you
know emmer is is a great advocate for
crypto to me lummus
um yeah tumi's gone now right I mean
he's on his way up unfortunately you got
John Federman instead I suspect he's
either fetterman or Oz right I don't
think either of them you know are going
to be pro-crypto right
probably not so you're right we have a
we have a lot of work to do in
Washington yeah
um you know I'm going to be beating the
drum that like this has nothing to do
with crypto I don't think Wall Street
got tied in to Congress you know after
after Madoff you know to try to defend
uh the stock exchanges
uh so
um but yeah the the perspective is there
uh that this is somehow crypto's problem
um you know we I think we really just
need to keep beating on that that these
are two separate things
another
um aspect of this that has generated
some level of discussion is that FTX um
sent uh set up an exchange or set up a
helps Ukraine set up a website that
allowed people to send money to
basically support the war effort so send
crypto directly to Ukraine
uh there's been some implications I
don't think there's any hard evidence of
this that it's you know some sort of
like money laundering operation or
something on the other hand you know it
could just be
you know uh something to help a cause
that SBF believed in um and it seems to
have generated uh quite a bit of uh
funds for them do you have any thoughts
on
um do either of you have any thoughts I
guess on the Ukraine connection
um you know you mentioned Ukraine
earlier in the context of Bitcoin
allowed Ukrainian refugees to uh get out
and take their money with them in a way
that basically no other Financial Tool
uh could via Hardware wallets
um but now we're getting into the realm
where uh crypto is actually allowing
people to fund a war effort
yeah I I don't know much about this
um you know Kraken actually get money to
our Ukrainian clients directly we gave
them back their fees that they had paid
and and we gave him actually the fees
from our Russian clients so Revenue that
was generated from Russia went to our
Ukrainian client said
um people received like over a thousand
dollars per person so you know we felt
like we should fund the individual
clients that have been loyal to us not
put money in the government's coffers
you know I mean these people are trying
to just get out of the country and live
so
um we went that route yeah I've heard
these rumors as well that that they were
uh that that basically they were
facilitating the transfer of money to
the Ukrainian government and that the
Ukrainian government was sending money
back to them somehow that you know that
there was some conspiracy to like from
the Democrats there's no verification
there like there's we see that they were
that they set up a route for money to go
to the bank of Ukraine but the thing
that's missing there is the money coming
back and there's not really an obvious
reason why that would be necessary but
yeah yeah that's just kind of floating
out there
um but one uh last couple things um I
before we get to some audience questions
uh you know Edward Snowden and a few
other people have raised this Prospect
of kind of the uh imminent introduction
of what are known as cbdc's Central Bank
digital currencies which would be a kind
of government generated version of
cryptocurrency programmable government
money is is how some people might put it
um this this tweet that he's referring
to talks about an experimental digital
dollar Pilots that is being done in
conjunction with some of the big Banks
and the New York fed uh just to be
perfectly clear uh it looks like that
idea was being kind of in the works
before this all happened
um but you know the pilot is preceding a
pace uh what do you think about this uh
cbdc question is it something we should
be worried about or something that
should be welcomed
on the one hand it could be the the
Gateway for a lot of people to get into
true crypto you know if the government
says uh you know you can get your tax
refund or you can get your EBT or you
can get um
a kind of airdrop payment that they want
to make uh any kind of relief payments
um if you can get that through a cbdc I
mean the government shockingly has a
very hard time giving money to people
um
and I mean even during covet they had a
hard time collecting it I mean they were
the IRS was was backlogged so
um you know I think on the one hand the
government needs a more efficient way of
collecting and paying out native people
uh on the other hand uh to be a total
dystopian Nightmare and all of money uh
you know if if this is mandated they
have to use this and I'm sure they'd be
looking to kill cash right after all
this out uh then you no longer have any
Finance privacy at all uh you know maybe
maybe it's not hard to see you know
another step after switches you know
some kind of uh china-like Sesame system
uh where you have basically a social
credit score and um you know they can
just from the top in Washington press a
button and turn off
all of your money or your ability to
spend your money
um based on your political beliefs or
the way uh you know what you're saying
on Twitter or whatever you know it's
just it's a really ridiculous amount of
power to give them and so
if it's just one option you know as an
alternative to cash that you can use
voluntarily I think that's great you
know many people would use that
especially especially the unbanked if
the government is saying this is going
to be our rail of Last Resort or digital
dollars everyone can use this it's just
like a Bitcoin wallet install it on your
phone and you know your address is your
social security number or something like
that you know it's like
yeah that could be nice but to to
mandate it to um
you know I think that is like full
dystopia and I think the government
really should have no business in money
I think we need a separation of money in
state and um you know I think if if
allowed to
uh to compete I think Bitcoin will win
in the end
can I ask uh just real quickly to follow
up on that you know from a from a kind
of libertarian perspective the fear
always tends to be the government is
going to muscle in and take over an
industry and you know do something like
a central bank digital currency when we
look at the internet you know which
obvious has longer routes but coming
online as a mass medium you know mostly
through the web in the 90s you know it
kind of turns out at least in the U.S
that it's not the government that is
really regulating things in the ways
that make people upset it's large
corporations that you know mostly one
massive market share because they had a
good product and expanded it you know
whether it's meta now or you know
Facebook and Twitter and like major
places do you worry about that in the
crypto space or do you think it's
actually different so that it's not
going to be uh you know binance you guys
coinbase
um like will it always be more open or
do we need to you know I mean obviously
be worried about Central Bank digital
currencies but also about you know
whatever becomes the GM Ford and
Chrysler of crypto
yeah we we do certainly need to be
worried about
um the big deal companies Kraken
included I mean I mean you shouldn't
trust us just because we say so uh I
think that um yeah I think in your Tweet
storm you said don't trust verify
absolutely and and you know please don't
leave all of your life savings on Kraken
spread it around mix it up leave only
what you active trading with and a great
thing about crypto is you can do
self-custody
um but yeah in the long run you know I
think we'll see more players like FTX
who uh come into the space because they
just want to make money and they're
going to try to build them out and but
you know I think more of the threat is
probably coming from the Legacy system
who
who wants to shut Bitcoin out or wants
to do Bitcoin in a way that works for
their business
and um
you know should should rightfully be
concerned about defy and you know being
disintermediate from the future
Financial world
I uh wanna we're gonna turn to the
audience questions in a second I want to
ask one more question because you
mentioned self-custody and this has been
the
um kind of Mantra of a lot of what our
people call the Bitcoin maximalists
their mantras like you know not your
keys not your coins
um kind of one of the highest profile
people along these lines is Michael
Saylor uh whose microstrategies has you
know a lot of money in Bitcoin
um and what he says uh here in this
interview with Fox Business is
um you know uh crypto may have been the
problem but Bitcoin is still the
solution
um it means you don't have to trust the
ftx's of the world
um I'm a big believer uh because I
believe that although crypto in this
case maybe the problem Bitcoins the
solution and may have made a million
Bitcoin maximalists with this crash so
what do you make of the Bitcoin maximum
list case I mean on one hand as someone
who runs an exchange I'm sure you don't
want people to have no money on
exchanges but does do people like sailor
have a point that people need to just
realize that self-custody you know
having total control and not relying on
intermediaries is the kind of safest
most secure option
yeah I mean first of all crypto is not
the problem here right like cash is not
the problem when a bank gets robbed the
problem is the bank robbers uh but uh
you know Bitcoin offers self-custody
every other cryptocurrency offers
self-custody I do think that that is one
solution you know I think people were
just kind of
um overly trusting of FTX for for many
of the reasons that we talked about
earlier
um
but the future I I do feel like there is
this on-chain world where people do take
custody of of the majority of their
funds and
um
you know they have they have full
control and and they don't rely on a
middleman to say yes or no to every
transaction that they make you know and
I mean as we saw in Canada I mentioned
the truckers uh they're innocent people
caught up in that in those account
freezes you know guys just were uh you
know selling coffee in the vicinity of
of the protest had their businesses shut
down because of you know the
government's action and you know these
like an executive order to do that
basically like you know a wartime power
um to freeze bank accounts without any
due process and so even if you think
you're legitimate person you're never
going to get in trouble you might just
be walking through the wrong protest at
some point
and have your bank account shut off
without notice and then what are you
going to do you don't have any money to
hire a lawyer now
because your bank account's gone so you
know Bitcoin is an insurance policy for
everyone self-custities and insurance
policy it's something you can have when
uh they come to take everything else
can I ask so can you make a quick case
for you are an intermediary right and
you know capitalism you know on the one
hand it allows people to be individual
but I mean it's the greatest mediation
system in the world where like you have
no idea who you're dealing with but
somehow what you need shows up at a
price you might be willing to pay what I
I agree with you uh you know about
self-custody and that will be I was just
talking with uh somebody today about
that you know and this is kind of like
it seems impossibly hard for most people
it's like when the first cars came out
like how the [ __ ] do you work all these
gears now we're used to it but make make
a briefcase for the intermediary for the
the role that Kraken plays and other
exchanges in you know in this Brave New
World of D5
yeah so we see ourselves as a as a
bridge from from the Legacy world to the
new world of of crypto
um you know most people coming in with
Fiat currencies to buy cryptocurrency
you know they're not they're not
starting out having earned
cryptocurrency at their job or something
like that
um however some companies do you know
Kraken pays people with cryptocurrency
if they want to do that uh so most
people are coming in with dollars to
point out you know we're published by a
non-profit and we accept Bitcoin for tax
deductible donations so all right
awesome the accept nft donations
uh you know we sold that we auctioned
off in nft last year which I believe is
trading at less than for what it was
purchased but we loved the person who
purchased it so well we certainly will
be yes cool
um so you know for for us yeah we're
that bridge right like most people the
vast majority of people in the world
don't have crypto yet they have some
form of national currency and so uh they
need a place you know just like a
currency exchange basically you know
when you're traveling to another country
you're at the airport you got to get the
local money and if you want to get into
crypto you want to trade nfts or you
just want to invest in Bitcoin you need
that kind of currency changer that can
Bridge the Legacy banking system the
traditional money to uh the new world
and and give you you know do that swap
for you get you into crypto but once you
have your crypto
um you know if you've bought it on
Kraken
you can withdraw it into your own
self-custody and then you're off do
whatever you want in the world of defy
or control your keys you can make trades
with other people without any middleman
involved it's purely done atomically on
chain fully transparent uh so we highly
recommend people do that you know after
after they have their coins if you're
comfortable if you trust yourself enough
uh take your coins off and carry on your
journey into crypto without needing that
trust of a centralized Exchange
can I ask just to follow up on the nft
question you know there is a court case
coming up of insider trading related to
nfts that were sold on open c
um and again this it seems to be wrapped
up in this coming desire to demonize
crypto
and again that seems to be there was a
guy who had advanced notice of what was
going to be listed on the front of
opensees so he would buy you know an nft
that he knew was going to be up there
because it was going to be worth more is
that another case of where you know
there's going to be a rush to demonize
what is seems to be and who knows in
this particular case or even with SPF
but you know uh kind of a legacy version
of fraud or criminality just getting
rolled into oh you know but it's worse
when it's you know when it's an nft it's
worse if it's you know insider trading
is worse if it's in crypto rather than
in a stock or Bond or something
yeah I mean we're we're certainly going
to see more of that just as
um
you know well to your point about this
SEC case I think it's going to be very
interesting to see whether this is
actually insider trading I think it's
um that nft was probably not a security
um you know just having Advanced
information as an employee you know I
think I think they allege that the crime
was actually against the company against
their employer uh it wasn't actually you
know the traditional kind of form of
insider trading
um but it'll be very interesting to see
how that case plays out but uh you're
right that you know every time we have a
new technology emerge
criminals go to that too start doing
what they've always been doing just in
in the new format you know they've they
use the telephone to scam people and
then they use the internet to scam
people and now they're using good
currency to scam people
um or you know I mean in the case of
openc
could have been anything you know they
could have been selling Pokemon cards uh
so
um it just so happens that you know
cryptocurrency is a new thing that now
people are touching and interacting with
and um scammers uh are are just going to
do what scammers do and you know scam
whoever they can scam it just really has
nothing to do with cryptocurrency but
yeah I think we'll just see see more of
that scammers get more familiar with the
technology
there's an audience question here that I
think goes to that issue we were just
talking about a minute ago about
self-custody
um going you know on and off ramps
getting people introduced to crypto and
it comes from Liberty DIY who says
government controls the on and off ramps
with kyc and kyc is short for know your
customer it's a regulation that requires
um pretty much any Financial entity to
verify the identity of their customers
um and in terms of financial privacy
that presents obvious problems um if
people do want to use these coins for
um to to transact in private and not
have every transaction linked back to
them there's ways around that there's
mixers the government has started going
after some of those methods
um what is your opinion about kyc is it
something that you think is should
legitimately is legitimate or
could be looked at and reformed in some
way
yeah I think it's a huge it's a huge
burden and I'm skeptical that it it
achieves the stated goal uh which is you
know to to basically prevent crime by
knowing who everyone is
um you know hackers and scammers are
able to get fake identity information
um or you know they'll pay people to set
up fake accounts for them so or those
steal accounts you know from people that
they hack so
um I think that it doesn't really stop
the most sophisticated criminals
uh and it puts a huge burden a huge
amount of overhead on the whole industry
and and everyone in the world and like I
said earlier there are a lot of people
that can't pass that bar they don't have
the information the ability to really
prove their identity
um so it leaves a lot of people out and
it creates these massive Treasure troves
of personal information for people to
hack and it's just happened over and
over again I mean even the government
gets hacked
of personal information and
uh you know with crypto because
everything is on the blockchain and it's
there forever the crypto change get
hacked and and you get a list of all the
addresses match up to all of the users
and you get those real identities
well then anyone can can see for for all
time you know unless like you said you
use a service like a mixer which are
coming under attack
um you might have a complete view into
someone's total Financial history for
what they've been doing with
cryptocurrency so that's pretty scary I
think that they're huge risks with with
doing kyc and creating this Treasure
Trove and I don't think it actually
prevents real crime I mean as we've seen
these banks have gotten massive hundred
million dollar billion off fine for
their lack of like doing it properly and
so
um I I think it's a it's a huge problem
and it's keeping a lot of people out and
I don't think it's really achieving the
goal
what would what case would you make for
the notion of financial privacy because
a lot of people and I think you're gonna
increasingly hear this as uh if if
cryptocurrency continues to uh grow in
popularity and especially privacy
related coins or tools that
um only bad people who have to hide the
only use case for cash and Bitcoin in
crypto is criminal activity like you
hear this a lot so is there a legitimate
case in your mind Jesse for financial
privacy
yeah I think so
um you know I mean if if everyone would
love to have more information about
everyone that they interact with uh but
you know I think it it possibly creates
a system where
um
people are not allowed to speak they're
not allowed to fund things that are
important to them uh because of the the
political blowback you know imagine
you're going for a job and I can just
look up and see
everything you've ever bought in life uh
you know it's already bad enough that I
can look at your Instagram account and
some people forget that they're going to
apply for it but imagine it's just
having a complete view in your financial
history right like I mean you would
always have to be paranoid that you know
you you bought something that disagreed
with whoever's interviewing you
um
I mean between businesses right like a
lot of the transactions that we make on
our competitors know where we're sending
our money around
um that would be awful right that would
that would expose a lot of
confidential strategic information about
what we're doing we don't want people
necessarily know who our business
partners are
so I mean there are a million reasons to
have Financial privacy uh you just don't
want the whole world knowing what you're
doing even if you're a good actor you
know it's not that something you're
doing something is illegal but but
um I feel like Financial privacy should
be a basic humanite
um just like you shouldn't be forced to
like disclose your passwords or you know
what's in your head
um
and uh you know I think the attacks on
these mixers are are highly problematic
because
um mixing is not inherently
wrong or or even illegal you know what's
what's illegal is laundering the
proceeds of of crime basically and if
you're not laundering the proceeds of
crime if you're just trying to achieve
Financial privacy with your own
legitimately earned money there's
nothing illegal about that
no you know and actually we're talking I
was thinking too you know it's it's a
weird conversations act that we're
having more and more but it's like this
is a country that was founded on
Anonymous political speech and you know
and the Supreme Court has said that's
money is speech and like I know people
who have you know when you try to you
know make political change like you are
going to incur enemies and kind of like
free speech and Anonymous speech
you know this is one of the ways that a
free Society in an open Society works
and again I I think you're right Jesse
you know it's one thing if the
government has you know a search warrant
and they are you know they're
investigating a crime and they present
through a legal structure where there's
due process and everything okay we want
this particular piece of information
that is a radically different
alternative than saying no the default
is we see everything you do because then
you get into a situation you know you
give me the data and I'll show you the
crime it's uh it's not good yeah and
also the enforcement mechanism for the
uh going after these mixers is a huge
problem too just because there's people
I did a documentary that we can put in
the show notes on this about or an
interview with some of the coin Center
guys about the tornado cash
issue which is tornado cash is a mixer
that is used uh on uh on ethereum and
um it was sanctioned because a group
connected with North Korea was
apparently using it to facilitate
weapons purchases so you can see that's
a legitimate national security issue but
at the same time by a sanctioning
everything that went through there
basically any coin that touched that
then can taint an entire network of
coins and it's it's a huge mess so uh
they got to figure out a better way to
kind of Target those kind of sanctions I
think
um there was another interesting
question here for Jesse from Tron what
do you think of the xrp lawsuit with the
SEC will it provide more clarity for
crypto law in the U.S and if you could
explain you know what he's talking about
there
unfortunately I don't think it's going
to give us more clarity
um I think it might keep the SEC at Bay
for a little while I think what we
really need for clarity though is is new
legislation uh because The Regulators
are still working off of these old laws
that are many decades old
and um I think we just need new we just
knew laws that contemplate from the
beginning
how Bitcoin should should be related
can I uh ask a question which it's
related but it's not exactly uh Jesse
what is it like to be building the
future of uh you know kind of of like
the money economy and things like that
because you know this is something I'm
older than you guys so like I remember
reading you know this kind of stuff in
80s cyberpunk fiction and stuff like
that but it is here and you are doing it
and like we're talking to you because of
a really bad situation
um you know that is probably going to
result in some bad stuff but I mean it
must be pretty [ __ ] cool to be doing
what you're doing
um you know is it or is it really just
the pain in the ass it's super cool it's
also extremely exhausting you know and
yeah like stuff like this
you know I don't like hanging out in
Washington DC but you know I'm surely
going to have to go out and now explain
the situation
uh so
you know they're constantly fires to put
out they're constantly attacks coming at
cryptocurrency I feel like the mission
is
um extremely important for the world for
Humanity and I think to to finally get
this uh completely permissionless
completely
um non-custodial uh money that isn't
controlled by any government
you know no Gatekeepers I think this is
just a huge leap forward for Humanity in
the way that the internet was was a huge
leap forward and you know I think it's
it's usually democratizing you know I
mean what the internet did for
information
um cryptocurrency will do for money
and I just could unlock all kinds of uh
you know economic growth and human
flourishing you know that we haven't
even imagined
so that is all super exciting you know
the mission uh is what keeps me going
and I think that's why a lot of people
are here in this case and um
you know so if you come to work a space
if that kind of stuff interests you
um it's just very exciting you know a
lot of people it's both their their work
and their Hobby and life passion and um
so yeah it's it's super exciting and fun
and sometimes very difficult and uh you
know we gotta we gotta do things we
don't like like you know put on a suit
but um yeah mostly fun
so I'm going to go down if you work at
reason you don't have to wear a suit I'm
just saying
I'm going to go to this
this audience question and then uh kind
of get your your final thoughts here uh
first there's a couple uh Jesse fans in
the comments Kraken OG proof of reserves
supports privacy coins no exchange token
Etc
lfg Jesse gigashad Jessie Chad
um there's uh where's my question
um there was uh oh here this was the
last question I wanted to bring up
Matthew istron what steps is Kraken put
into place to prevent something like
this from happening to them I mean I
don't think uh the exact thing that's
gonna happen to FTX is going to happen
to Kraken because you don't have that
kind of arrangement going on but I mean
other players in the crypto industry
have been touched by the FTX Scandal
because of you know intermingling their
business with them
um so what I guess kind of business
lessons have you taken away from this
oh well certainly I mean we knew this
before I mean we've been around for so
long we've seen everything but
um you know certainly be careful with
who you trust your money with I think
that's number one I mean even for
equipped businesses you know we always
tell people not your keys not your coins
you know meaning if you don't actually
sell custody you know you're trusting
someone else to do custody for you and
they could screw it up
uh
so obviously don't keep more than you
can afford to lose with another venue
um you know FTX is doing a lot of crazy
stuff it's clear
they basically had no structure to their
business certainly not what you would
expect a regulated financial services
company
um you know their whole team it was we
were talking to some some of the same
investors at theme time you know and the
investors are so impressed fbx was doing
with like 50 people what Kraken was
doing with like 3 000 people
I was like well yeah are they really
doing everything that we're doing or you
know is this whole thing just like a
facade and you know it turns out like
[ __ ] security team is over 100 people
right so like how could FTX with 50
people in the whole company be doing as
much for security as we're doing and it
turns out I mean they're basically doing
nothing right like there was basically
nothing under the water this was just
like all surface level stuff
and the whole thing was run by like a
few people
um
who had very little business experience
if you look at kraken's uh leadership
team you know it's all fairly seasoned
people who've worked at other reputable
places
um
you know obviously that doesn't mean
there's nothing you know nefarious going
on but
um you know I think when you look at
something
you know I think a lot of people looked
at FTX trading then you know they just
it was a good place to trade and they
didn't think so much about whether
it was Fort Knox you know like where
they're gonna be a good place to to put
their life savings and I think all the
signs said that this is not Fort Knox
you know this is a very like shallow
kind of operation that's you know very
like
doesn't have much for infrastructure or
for
you know support teams and things like
that so um
yeah I think just look out for the signs
you can only do so much with like 50
people you know you're you're not going
to have huge uh huge uh accounting
system that that is doing you know
real-time reconciliations and you know
it sounds like these guys didn't do
reconciliations for three years
uh which is not surprising so
um
let's say yeah look at the team look out
for the professionalism I think the team
size actually does matter even though
you know in Silicon Valley we know you
can get a lot done with with very few
people but I think when you're building
a Fort Knox
um
maybe not so much
that that's a good uh kind of final
warning to issue to the consumers
um I think to wrap up I'd just like to
ask you you know the the name of the
stream is FTX meltdown and the future of
crypto so when you look forward to the
future of crypto
um you know the prospects for it
especially after all we've been talking
about here what do you see like what's
your forecast over the next you know two
to five years
yeah I hope we come out of this bear
Market in the next two years we've got
another Bitcoin having coming up that's
usually a catalyst to launch this out of
a bear Market
um I hope that we do get some
not just regulatory Clarity uh but good
regulation uh good legislation you know
I think there's there's a right way and
wrong way to do it and I think you know
the way New York did it for example it
was very bad I think they've shut up you
know prevented their their residents
from huge amounts of potential gains
over the years by by shutting them out
of a lot of opportunity
um
so I hope that we get some good
legislation in
um or or maybe we just remove some
legislation that's a problem uh you know
I think the industry is going to gonna
move past this and and we'll remember
this uh and I think people be more
careful in the future
um I'm hoping we on board the next
billion users you know by five years
from now and you know beyond that I'm
looking forward to a global Bitcoin
standard for the world and uh everybody
getting paid and doing everything in
Bitcoin and uh will only need Fiat
currencies to pay our taxes maybe maybe
not even now
here's to that thank you so much Jesse
Patel that was a wonderful uh
educational conversation so thank you
for joining us thank you thank you Nick
um and thank you all for watching we
will see you next week